we believe that games like books movies
and music should be celebrated and
enjoyed by countless generations we're
passionate about preserving and
celebrating the games you own the
classics of the past and the genres you
love to play that's why two years ago we
launched the Xbox backward compatibility
program to bring Xbox 360 games to your
Xbox one and we've seen tremendous
growth in the program today our library
of games stands at 385 titles and over
half of Xbox one gamers have played a
backward compatible game but I've heard
your feedback and you want more today
I'm pleased to announce an exciting
expansion to the program
[Applause]
our team of engineers are working hard
to bring us some of your favorite
original Xbox game to today's Xbox one
library including a fan favorite that
I'm asked about often by the community
crimson skies and it looks great and
like the Xbox 360 games og games Lua
look better and play better across the
Xbox one family we'll have more to share
about this program when it launches
later this year I'm proud of the library
of games available today on Xbox one
all of them will benefit from the
performance and power when you play them
on Xbox one X but we won't stop there
I'm excited announce that if you own
Gears of War four forts of horizon three
Killer Instinct Halo Wars 2 or minecraft
will providing 4k updates to these
titles for free
and we already have over 30 titles from
our third-party partners that are
planning to provide free updates as part
of our Xbox 1x enhanced program titles
like Final Fantasy 15 Resident Evil 7
Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon wildlands and
Rocket Lee just to name a few
this means you probably already have a
large library of titles that you own
today that will automatically get better
on Xbox 1x today we showcase some of the
world's greatest creators with a lineup
of different types of games for every
type of gamer we showed you the largest
and most diverse lineup of new games
that have ever appeared on our stage
from every corner of the globe from
developers large and small 42 games
including 22 with console exclusivity on
Xbox one and you're also going to be
able to play all of the biggest
cross-platform blockbusters on Xbox one
and every game will play great across
the Xbox one family and on Xbox one X
runs every single game you've seen even
better so if you haven't joined the Xbox
one family now's the time this week
you'll find Xbox 1s available in the US
for $249 and on November 7th will begin
worldwide rollout of Xbox one X the
world's most powerful console at $4.99
be the first to experience unrivaled
power and performance on the Xbox one we
close today's show by looking to the
future with a really great partner
they've been with us from the earliest
days of
Scorpio and they're building an
incredible game that takes advantage of
the power and performance of the Xbox
one family and the new Xbox 1x